aluminum metal can be recycled from
scrap metal by melting the metal to
evaporate impurities calculate the
amount of heat needed to purify one mole
of aluminum originally at 298 Kelvin by
melting it the melting point of aluminum
is 933 Kelvin the molar heat capacity of
aluminum is 24 joules per mole Kelvin
and the heat of fusion of aluminium is
10 point 7 kilojoules per mole all right
so we don't think about the heat they
needed to raise its temperature from 298
Kelvin to raise the temperature of this
one mole of aluminum from 298 Kelvin to
933 Kelvin and we're going to do that by
looking at the molar heat capacity and
then we need to add to that the heat of
fusion the heat necessary to actually
melt it so let's do that in steps so
heat heat needed heat needed to raise
temperature sure by how many how many
how much we are raising the temperature
by we're going from 298 to 933 so see if
you're raised by 2 you get to 300 and
then you have to raise by another 633 so
that's going to be so we're raising our
temperature by 635 Kelvin that's to get
it to the melting point so the heat
needed to raise temperature by 635
Kelvin well we have we have one mole one
mole of aluminum I can write 1.0 o to
show that we have two significant dujour
three significant digits there one mole
of aluminum times the specific or the
molar heat capacity I should say so 24
joules per mole per mole Kelvin times so
this right over here would be the amount
of heat to raise it by one Kelvin but
now let's multiply by we have to raise
it by 635 Kelvin 635 Kelvin and the
units work out moles cancel with moles
Kelvin cancels with cancels Kelvin
cancels with Kelvin and then we get to
let's see
we get my calculator out here so 24
times 635 is equal to 15,000 240 and are
we're taking the product of a bunch of
stuff three significant figures two
significant figures three significant
figures so we should only we should
write only two significant figures so
we'll round to 15,000 joules so this is
going to be fifteen fifteen thousand
joules just to raise the temperature to
933 Kelvin and then we have the heat
heat of fusion heat to melt once at
melting point melting point well that is
going to be one mole one mole times the
heat of fusion times ten point seven
kilojoules kilojoules per mole so this
is going to give us ten point seven
kilojoules or if we want to write it in
joules so this is ten point seven
kilojoules which is equal to ten
thousand seven hundred joules and so the
total the total is going to be the sum
of these so we could say it is twenty
five thousand seven hundred but we only
have two significant figures here so we
could round that and so we could say
twenty six thousand twenty-six thousand
joules or I guess we could write two
twenty six twenty six kilojoules all
right now Part B Part B the equation for
the overall process of extracting
aluminum from aluminum oxide is shown
below
alright shown below which which requires
less energy recycling a little existing
aluminum or extracting aluminum from
aluminum oxide justify your answer with
a calculation alright so this reaction
this reaction right over here if and
this is this gives us the the heat
sorry for a mole of the reaction so if
you get a mole of aluminum oxide you put
in this much heat you're going to get
two moles of aluminum and 1.5 moles of
molecular oxygen so the equation the so
let's see the equation for the overall
process so to extract to extract one
mole one mole of aluminum from aluminum
oxide requires so this much heat will
produce 2 moles so to do one mole you
just have to have half of that requires
1675 kilojoules divided by 2 so this is
going to be 1675 divided by 2 is equal
to let's see it's going to be eight
hundred thirty seven point five eight
hundred thirty seven point five eight
hundred thirty seven point five
kilojoules
you know that's half here and had four
significant digits here and I still have
four significant digits extracting doing
it from which requires less recycling
existing aluminum or extracting it well
to to recycle one mole requires we just
figure it out twenty six kilojoules
twenty six kilojoules everything here's
some Quilt kilojoules which is much less
energy which is much less energy and we
are done